علمت CNN حصريًا أن أوكرانيا
تريد رؤوسًا حربية ذخائر عنقودية مميتة
من أسلحة الولايات المتحدة المحظورة من قبل
أكثر من 100 دولة والتي
تقول أوكرانيا الليلة إنها ستغير مسار
هذه الحرب ، ويأتي هذا في الوقت الذي
يصعد فيه بوتين شخصيًا تهديده النووي
فيما يتعلق بتهديده.  تحذير نووي ،
أنت محق في أن التهديد
يتزايد ، فلماذا تخفي الحقيقة الآن
فيما يتعلق بما إذا كانت روسيا
ستكون أول من يستخدم واحدًا بغض النظر عن
الظروف التي قد تكون جيدة إذا لم
تكن أول من يستخدم واحدًا ، فلا يمكن أن
يكون  ثانيًا استخدام واحد لأن الضربة النووية
على أراضينا ستحد إلى حد كبير من
قدراتنا ، وأشار
بوتين بوضوح إلى icbms النووي
وليس الأسلحة النووية التكتيكية لأن
تلك الأسلحة التي تمتلكها روسيا والولايات المتحدة هي
التي من شأنها أن تسبب مثل هذا الضرر
لمنع أي دولة من الاستجابة.  في
الضربة الثانية بحيث يكون هذا تهديدًا كبيرًا
ولدى بوتين بالطبع
أكبر مخزون حوالي 4200 رأس حربي نووي باليستي عابر للقارات بالإضافة إلى
بما
يقدّر بحوالي 2000 سلاح نووي تكتيكي ،
لكن بوتين يجعل هذا التهديد
ينبثق ويفعل ذلك شخصيًا مع
ضغط ظهره بقوة على
الحائط لأنه يعلم أن غزوه
لم ينته وفقًا للخطة التي قالها أيضًا
اليوم وأنا أقتبس منه  فيما يتعلق
بمشكلة المعدات بقدر ما أستطيع أن
أقول أنه تم حلها بالفعل ،
ولكن إذا كان هناك شيء آخر يحتاج إلى
اهتمامنا الخاص في مكان ما بالطبع ،
فسأطلب منك مزيدًا من المعلومات ،
فسنتعامل معها بالتأكيد وبأسرع وقت
ممكن قبول  قد تشعر بمشاكل مع معدات
ناعمة مثل هذا القبول
بالنسبة لك حتى يقول بوتين إن هذه مشكلة كبيرة
وأنه مجبر على الاعتراف بذلك
بسبب ما يراه جنوده
كل يوم ويتم تسجيله الآن على شريط
يتحدث عن أننا كنا  مشاركة
المحادثات معك بين
الجنود وعائلاتهم وأريد أن ألعب
هذا من أجلك ، فهذه مكالمة تم الحصول عليها حديثًا
مكالمة حديثة بين جندي روسي
وموظفه  ارجع إلى المنزل ، استمع
إليها ،
نعم ، هرب بعيدًا ، ماذا بعد خمسة أيام
تحت المطر الغزير دون
نوم ، احترس إذا لم
يسمحوا لنا بالمغادرة في ديسمبر ، سنذهب بعيدًا
أيضًا ، لا يمكنك تخيل أننا نعيش في
مستنقع  كل شيء يتسرب ، ليس لدينا
نوم ، ولا طعام ، ولا طعام ،
ولا نوم ، ولا طعام ، ولا شيء ،
والوقت بالتأكيد ليس في صف بوتين